when so-called Islamic state captured
Mosul in June 2014 it proclaimed a
caliphate it used the city as the
staging ground for an unprecedented
information war want to inspire tax
across the world but Sky News has
learned that as the so-called caliphate
has shrunk in Iraq so has the digital
version by 36 percent over two years
according to an analysis of is secret
communication channels that doesn't mean
it's propaganda is any less deadly
though as the Westminster attack shows
instead it has adapted for Islamic state
propaganda is everything if you look at
its actions through the lens of
propaganda it all begins to make sense
their most atrocious acts their most
counterintuitive operations they all
suddenly begin to fall into place it's
all about ideology perpetuating that
ideology and in that sense propaganda
and terrorism are one and the same thing
for the Islamic state in 2015 during
February is put out 892 pieces of
propaganda photos videos written reports
and audio the corresponding month this
year though I has put out only 570
pieces online a drop of more than a
third and the type of content has
changed in 2015 is didn't focus on the
headings or jihad 53% of the output was
dedicated to depicting is as a utopia
only 39% was about war this year those
swapped as coalition forces moved in 80%
of Isis output was about jihad and only
14% about utopia sources in UK
counterterrorism confirmed that the
quantity and quality of is propaganda
has declined but their focus has shifted
to lone wolf attacks this London startup
uses tech to counter those messages what
needs to be done to a certain extent to
counter Isis and - is to mimic their
tactics to actually identify individuals
that are vulnerable and engage in
one-to-one conversations with those
individuals and it's hard work but with
modern technology can be done and the
only way we're ever going to really turn
the tide on this is if we start to do
that kind of hard work in the digital
space in the exact same way the
extremists are doing it Islamic state
has always used technology to spread its
message it used to be Twitter and
YouTube thousands of videos but has
forced off those platforms it was very
quick to embrace secret encrypted
messaging apps like telegram that means
it doesn't read such a mass audience but
the people it does reach a lot more
determined and a lot more difficult for
the security services to spot the attack
on Westminster was much less elaborate
than the ones like Paris and Brussels
directed by is itself but it shows the
reach of the group I reach the will
outlast the so-called Caliphate Tom
Cheshire Sky News